oh cool your eyes I'm gonna put some in
your mouth you want me to keep putting
smudges off the lens please consider
subscribing okay note special about
today everybody I got my III media bag
we're going to III know way better
we have been joined by a close friend of
mine talented filmmaker Clinton Jones
Clinton Jones now a member of the
corridor crew
[Applause]
[Music]
so ladies and gentlemen please give a
round of applause for Clayton Jones
one thing you see a lot in movies is
when a bad guy has a good guy in a dire
situation and it's up to that good guys
trusty unexpected sidekick to slide them
a weapon or a gun in order to take out
the bad guy and win the day it's
something we see a lot but if you were
actually in that situation how difficult
would it be for your friend to save you
we're gonna have teams of two where one
person will be sliding and one person
will be catching and it's up to that
person to complete the mission before
the other team does and take out the
other team ten friends save friends
[Music]
Sliney strategy which I'm a shuffleboard
master so just you know kind of channel
my intuition on this one for sure
or maybe this
hey this is gonna be the wall I promise
[Music]
[Applause]
the floor is it buffered right here
inside it's not like I'm so sorry I'm
sorry I'm just gonna toss it better he
was just doing like like this one hey
quit I'm going to throw the gun you know
in this oh yeah good win and three times
over all three of them all of them in
the blue don't die McClane
[Applause]
Jarra kimchi from it down low this is
potent stop caramel is potent this is a
jar of fermented cabbage unopened as you
can see look at the bulging right
this thing's about bags so let's open
this thing first we lay down a
protective layer my goal is to open this
open that this is my second job keeps
you have ever open ever in my life I'm
gonna open this thing up try and get the
nastiest sound possible out of this jar
so this would be good for some like have
you heard this before I've heard this
once before that's why I'm excited to
show you guys
it's all over your shirt mm-hmm yeah
it's all over Goku was it delicious yeah
man I wash my shirt now
about seven years ago I think I was a
fan of Freddie and a quarter honestly
wasn't even channel there's a whole
story we can get into the whole story
you want to do a story section I did a
lot of effects together I helped with
effects I was doing my youtube channel
here at the time I didn't listening sama
Nico was sync did all the VFX were
sinking yeah and then I kind of been all
over the places worked at rocketjump for
a time did freelance I try and travel
once a year like that's might that's my
goal I love Asian he's like my favorite
play end of the last year I went to Bali
for yoga then I went to Shanghai to meet
Jimmy is for Andrew and then I went to
Japan for a second time Japan is my
favorite place in the whole world I was
there for like two and a half week so my
family is in Georgia I had Thanksgiving
there went to Utah did a bunch of hiking
in Utah loved hiking and the outdoors
stuff camping it's good time up rock
climbing I'm a huge rock climber so any
outdoor exploration kind of stuff let's
write up my alley have an idea grab the
paper towel okay cover this up a mystery
Flay Oh close your eyes and close our
mystery flavors
what's going on so trick going on
SSC a fork in your hand and then you're
bringing me into the bathroom with snowy
snow okay you have to close your eyes
I'm gonna put something in your mouth I
wouldn't lead you astray you know I'm
not gonna do anything that like would
damage our friendship or friendship
okay I've known you for a long time I
trust you yeah okay get ready to run
your next run your net here goes nothing
I'm just kidding here okay bro
assignment all right that was that was
further that was for fun that was for
laughs this is for real which will also
be for life sorry some grade-a kimchi
yeah yeah after we work out we go get a
BB q now that they like they know me and
Brett at the place we go to
yeah just bring us like a whole thing
again chances we always ask for true is
awesome only damn it I'll blindfold me
why what do you got back there
when it's got a tasty treat for you
pinky promise
needy promise of course anything that
wouldn't hurt you okay okay we'll spy
you for sure why does it smell like a
bathroom in here just kimchi brain I was
pretty good though guys we have one more
for Ren who should we summon
I failed you
round two everything could end right
here
dude why do I have to wear a helmet for
just sliding 3 2 Nico I'm just working
don't it felt glorious to shoot Jake
right in the leg
Thank You Jake
we need your assistance I wouldn't I
wouldn't do anything to damage our
friendship you we need you to close your
eyes and I gotta put some in your mouth
you'd smoke in here I can smell whatever
you're about to make me eat I can smell
it and it smells spicy and the look I'm
a little Billy for me
sounds like a mix of like broccoli and
spice you're close to the smells like
like in cabbage man I hate cabbage no
I'm not allergic to cabbage but I don't
like it okay you're about to make me eat
it like in Brussels sprout right now no
gonna make me eat a Brussels sprout
right that was the process you said you
wouldn't do anything to tarnish our
friendship smells like Brussels
sprouts give you a small dose I don't
get Korean barbecue
[Applause]
oh god no dude I'm out
can I get some more you're the back hmm
just a great day one wait that's the
office was he not
he gave me news like dude I hate cabbage
what is it it's my day one at quarter to
Joel has been has been great